okay so we have finished the day of this
my dear friend amin whom i know since i
don't know when and whenever i have a
class i'm teaching and i don't know five
minutes before how to teach it i will
call i mean and ask him for help
for example on this scene
so he will take us about spread of
information in networks
yeah thanks christian um what christian
is not you know did not tell you is that
he was actually my mentor at my very
first internship
uh at microsoft research
i won't tell you how long ago
quite a while ago
no it's a it's always a pleasure uh to
to hear from you
um
wondering if the people at the door are
coming in or
or not
change the you know what i wanted to
cover
uh quite a bit after uh
matt's talk i thought you know um since
he talked about the equilibrium
structure and the you know sort of games
and you know sort of a structure of
equilibrium then that is the structure
of equilibrium
on
networks
i'll talk about
you know sort of some of the connections
of that to graph models and stochastic
processes on networks
a specifically i'm going to talk about
this you know spread of innovations um
game dynamics and network structure and
most of it is built on the um joint work
with um
andrea um montenori
so the motivating question is you know
sort of when you look at the diffusion
of behavior or technology in the social
network and i'm going to look at it as
the dynamics of the game um i'm going to
you know sort of model it as the dynam
best response dynamics of the game on a
network
and you know try to drive the the
equilibrium of the game the you know
sort of uh
the evolutionary dynamics and then come
back to sort of interpret this in the
context of social networks
so
this pretty much
is the same as matt's last slide you
know when you think about the you know
sort of a spread of technology or you
know sort of a behavior in a social
network you can think of it in different
ways
for example you can model it as a
contagion process since that you adopt
a technology an innovation or you know a
behavior when you come in contact with
others
uh who have adopted it so in that sense
your mental model is that the you know
the technology sort of spreads like a
virus
um or you can say you know sort of you
know think of it as social learning so
you learn about you know sort of the
payoff of this you know sort of
of an action uh through interactions
with others for example in the context
of hybrid corn you know you're a farmer
you drive by a farm you see they have
you know uh
planted this new type of corn and it has
yielding you know better results
um
and you know sort of these two are
similar to each other or you can think
of you know sort of the dynamics as um
you know sort of the dynamics of the you
know peer pressure or peer influence
so for a lot of actions and matt you
know sort of talked about this like
adoption of a new technology like you
know sort of whether you're um choosing
you know sort of you know you're on
facebook or on instagram you're using uh
you know microsoft or uh
uh you know sort of a pc or you know an
apple computer or even um for you know
sort of you know that the way you dress
uh the political party that you're part
of
the you know the you know sort of the
religious you know sort of institution
that you're part of you know whether you
go to a mosque or a synagogue or a
church
um
is influenced by people close to you the
sense that you have a very strong
incentive to conform
to take the same action as you know sort
of people in your uh social networks so
you think about this as you know you can
model this as the dynamics of uh
of a coordination game even you know
sort of choosing which side of the road
you drive on
you really want to have the same you
know so choose the same side as uh
everyone else in your uh
so i'm going to think of this as a game
on a network the you know the players or
the notes
uh let's say they can take two actions
plus one or minus one
and um
so
x i is the action of node i
and i'm think of it as you know the
payoff matrix so if you take the action
plus and your neighbor also takes the
you know sort of action plus you get you
know sort of
a
this is a coordination game i want you
know sort of the people to have the
higher incentive to take the same action
as their neighbors what this means is
that a is bigger than d and b is bigger
than c
so
you know when you take an action you
look at you know sort of everyone else
around you you know your social network
what other actions they have you know
sort of taken and you get a payoff of
you know sort of
uh from each of these interactions you
added up that's your total payoff
so here is a simple example you want to
say you want to choose a cell phone
provider you know either say plus is a
tnt and minus is verizon
um
so you know if your friend is uh in the
same network as you probably may have a
higher uh payoff because maybe you're
not paying for the minutes
you know sort of the the in-net for you
know if you're talking within the net
for you you know sort of it costs you
less
and let's say between the two here you
know as an example like maybe a tnt has
a better reception you know gives you
the newest iphone so all things equal
you have a slight
you know preference for
uh you know sort of joining att
so the type of calculation you know sort
of a note i in the network
uh would make is that it looks that you
know sort of how many of his neighbors
are taking the action plus how many
taking the action minus the payoff would
be
for the plus is 6n plus i plus 2n minus
i and you know
see if the action plus has a higher
payoff
to take that otherwise you take the you
know action minus
um
it's not hard you know these numbers are
less important it's not hard to see that
there is a threshold
so for every you know sort of depending
on this
uh payoff matrix if
above a certain threshold of your
neighbors take the action plus you take
the action plus otherwise you take
action minus
so
another way of
writing it is that you can say for every
i there is an h i such that the best
response is the sign of h i sum up the
you know x j t a j in the neighborhood
of i
so you just you know add up the plus
ones and minus ones and then depending
on your sort of the payoff matrix you
have to uh
you know add this h i and without loss
of generality i'm going to assume h i is
bigger than zero
so plus action is a little bit more
advantageous
um so then you can think about this best
response dynamics you know people
occasionally check their neighborhood
and they see you know who is doing what
and they may change their action to
increase their payoff
and it's not hard to see that you know
the best response increases this
potential function
this is a sort of a
potential game every time somebody takes
the best response and changes its
response in you know sort of its action
in response to the action of its
neighbors this function increases
so that tells you that the best response
dynamics converges to an equilibrium
essentially to one of the local optima
of this potential function
and the potential function can have you
know several local optimal so you can
have you know the game can have
different equilibrium
again we saw that you know sort of matt
talked about the
you know the the equilibrium having this
lattice structure um
yes
um
well let's look at this example so let's
say h r is point one
um let's say this black nodes are taking
the action plus and the white nodes are
taking the action minus
nobody has an incentive to change right
just three four years ago for example
this person has two you know two of his
neighbors taking the action plus two are
taking action minus plus is the slightly
advantageous so it will take the action
plus
and a node here
uh has three neighbors that are taking
the action minus so it's gonna stay on
this
so this is one equilibrium
so if you think about the best response
dynamics it stays at this equilibrium
now
you know imagine that um you have one
note that you know sort of here
um you know you allow for some noise so
let's say this node gets too excited
about the you know new iphone or you
know for some reason you know makes a
mistake and switches its action to plus
now all of a sudden it's best response
for these two
to switch to the action plus
now you know sort of this noise you sort
of can sort of grow this region it can
also shrink it but in order to shrink it
i will need more than one percent to
make a mistake so if you think you know
introduce some noise
it actually creates a drift towards the
expansion in sort of the new technology
superior technology or the you know sort
of in the jargon of the sort of uh
you know sort of uh km kmr or the risk
dominant action you know sort of uh uh
you know sort of takes over everybody
will you know sort of uh add a little
bit noise to the system everybody will
switch from minus to plus
is that clear
i had a hole in the middle
uh no the whole sort of fills in quickly
imagine this vertex is
minus
still so imagine you know sort of then
the nodes that are
in
right at the border
of the white region inside
the best response is to switch to black
to the plus action so it starts
shrinking
so you don't even
at the corners yes but then once that
person switches the person next to it
will switch
okay so even you don't even need to
introduce the noise the other sort of
the inside will shrink
uh so this was you know sort of uh
uh you know observed in the paper by
trying doing the talk
in a sort of but it was seen as sort of
human
like the icing model uh also you know
physics this is discussed in the company
sort of named nucleation
like when you have a sort of soda you
shake it you know bubbles form that same
sort of
so
now
you know there are sort of different
ways to look at the noisy best response
dynamics i'm going to look at that you
know sort of introduce this noise
you know in a particular way uh to make
the you know sort of the markov chain um
easier to analyze so the dynamics that
we're gonna look at is gonna be
asynchronous so it's you know strategy
revision at the arrival of a plus one
clock so once in a while a vertex wakes
up looks at this neighborhood and it's
gonna revise this action
so the probability that it takes the
action y
is e to the power beta
y times this quantity
so it's it's not too hard to see that
you know sort of essentially this is
some sort of the soft max
if beta goes to infinity
you know it becomes exactly the best
response action you want y to be have
the same sign as the
as this quantity
right if beta is a smaller you allow for
some error
the nice thing about this uh you know
sort of way of doing the you know best
noisy best response is that it defines a
reversible markov chain with the
following in a sort of stationary
distribution the
you know sort of probability of the
particular configuration is e to the
power beta
and that's the potential function that i
showed
so it's better times the value of the
potential function
again you know these are called logit
dynamics or global dynamics in a sort of
mathematical physics
yes
so this is like the probability that x i
takes action by conditioned on the state
of its the neighborhood
yes i'm assuming that hr's are all
positive because everybody is playing
the same game
in the sense that um
let's say you know sort of if at t is
better than verizon it's better for
everybody
it's different depends on the degree
yes proportional to the degree of
in the sense that if you have a very
sort of
a large degree and everybody in your
neighborhood is taking action plus or
minus you have a much sort of higher
incentive to take the same action just
because your payoff is going to be the
difference between the two players
so essentially h i
is some fixed value that depends on the
gain times the degree of time
is this clear
so why is this important because i
started from you know with started from
a game and i looked at the you know sort
of equilibria of the game and the game
had several equilibria
now you know usually you know sort of
equilibrius like sort of a game
theoretic notion used for prediction so
you want to say if people are you know
sort of in this uh game playing you know
sort of what's going to be a likely
outcome now again with many equilibria
you know the prediction becomes you know
sort of uh
harder because which one of these
equilibria are going to be selected
so if you just look at you know sort of
best response dynamics you know you
could you know
sort of in that grid you could be you
know putting you know sort of a small
boxes here and there there could be
exponentially many equilibrium
but by introducing this noise i'm
essentially selecting for the most
stable equilibrium
so that's a that way you can refine your
prediction so to refine the notion of
equilibrium
um
now
um
sort of uh i'm by the way it's not hard
to see that this measure concentrates
along plus one vector as beta goes to
infinity because then beta goes to
infinity and essentially as i said you
know sort of you the major concentrates
around the
you know sort of the superior technology
you know everybody will be taking the
action plus one
right it's different from better equal
to infinity right sort of the limit you
can sort of uh
consent you know sort of your major
concentrates around that estate
now
the you know sort of maybe the next
you know sort of natural question to ask
is that when you look at this dynamics
how long does it take for it to reach to
this you know sort of a stable state in
which everybody is taking the action
plus
so that's you know i'll call that the
hitting time of you know sort of
reaching this you know all plus it's the
you know sort of the
the time it will take for you to even
sort of be reasonably sure
that you have reached that state
[Music]
yes you know sort of the worst from the
worst case starting point so if you are
at all plus then you're gonna be there
you know let's say you started from the
you know
minus yeah wait but i don't understand
you still have better not internet
so will you not always have fluctuations
um
yes i have fluctuations but this is a
heating time so i'm starting somewhere
and i want to know how long it will take
for me to you know get to that neighbor
like hit that
out plus once
but once i'm at the one plus you know
i'm going to start moving it up like the
heating time is sort of
[Music]
give the time it will take
uh for the dynamics to reach this all
class and so that's important for the
prediction right so if the you know sort
of it takes exponential time for you to
get to a particular state maybe you
cannot really just say oh that's the
only equilibrium i'm going to care about
because it will take a very long time
yes
plus i was expecting that it's instantly
to the minus
yes yes yes i haven't yeah very good
that's a very good question um so
i'm cheating a little bit in the sense
that when you know ellison and kmart
looked at a slightly different dynamics
they looked at the dynamics in which you
do the best response action with
volunteer one minus epsilon
and you take the action the wrong action
the probability epsilon and they analyze
that dynamics that dynamics defines a
markov chain but that markov chain is
irreversible i'm sorry yeah it's like
it's not a very nice work of change i
know this but that's this epsilon is the
probability of mistake and then you know
sort of um
[Music]
different graphs one was lined to the
power j
in which you know you put the vertices
on a line every percent interacts with
you know
up to k vertices on the left and up to k
vertices on the right so this is a graph
in which you have local interactions
like you just interact with people
around you and said that you know that
you know the time it will take to get r
plus is absolutely power minus 10
of k
and the complete graph where everybody
is interacting with everybody
the hinting time is exponentialness
so essentially also they look at the
paper the
message there is that if you have a
small number of neighbors or if you have
local interaction
you have you know you expect that you
know sort of you hit that alt plus
quickly but when you have global
interaction like a complete graph it
will take a very long time
is the statement clear
i know this is the last talk you've been
at in a sort of
oh god
yeah so you expect that you're sort of
in a very connected network you know the
diffusion spreads quickly and then
loosely connected yeah and that's one of
the things i'm going to get to
it is surprising in the sense that it's
the opposite of say
epidemics epidemic models in the
epidermic models where you have high
degree vertices where you have very
connected networks and sort of the you
know the the virus spreads very quickly
here the technology spreads
slowly the new technology let's say the
superior technology spreads very slowly
and
sort of in a well-connected network and
quickly in a loosely connected network
um
but it's one of the reasons you know
sort of facebook or microsoft
is it's very hard to you know sort of
compete with right because of the strong
network effect uh if i come up tomorrow
with the
with this you know sort of social
network or instant messenger that's a
little bit better than facebook
messenger um this will be very hard for
me to you know get everybody to switch
because like they're all using writing
and they're talking sort of using that
technology to uh talk amongst each other
so what's the problem to get to have the
population or is the problem to
get to from n minus 1 to n
oh very good i'll get to this it's a
very good question
um
give me five 10 minutes i'll get there
yes is
are not normalized for high degree
agents
and if i have a very i if you explained
before if i have if i'm a very high
degree agent and i'm comparing the two
options the more neighbors i have the
more electronic changing
fantastic so it's a very good question
the question is are we here talking
about the degree or something else so
here you have a low degree graph and
here you have your skills sort of
extremely high degree graph is the
degree the one that you know sort of
determines the areas or so
um but it's something else whatever the
open interaction could mean many things
so the question that i want to you know
sort of address is you know sort of what
you guys are asking the right question
what is the graph theoretic property
that captures the rate of convergence
good
and you know so and then the second
question is you know so when you look at
the dynamics where does it get stuck
like you know is it like the first few
steps the last step
she knows me too well that's where she
says expansion
so
this is the goal for today's talk you
know one find the graph theoretic
property that captures convergence
and then you know demonstrate on
specific graph sequences specifically
expanders you know finite range graphs
and small works uh sort of to
demonstrate that so it turns out that
the graph theoretic property that
captures the rate of convergence
is
this you know sort of tilted cut width
um
it's
in a sort of if you you know sort of
have done your working algorithms is
very related
very close to the notion of cut without
a graph
um
it says and you know i know the
definition is a little bit long let me
you know sort of parse it imagine you
have a linear ordering of your vertices
if you you know order your vertices in
some linear order then you can look at
the size of the cut
you know at every in a sort of prefix so
you can look at the first t vertices
that would give you the subset st you
can look at the number of edges that's
the cut you have to subtract for this
sum of h i in s that's sort of the you
know sort of the force
that you know uh
you know that
forces you from you know switching from
action minus to plus so you look at the
difference of these two you look at the
maximum overall t
and then you look at the ordering that
gives you the minimum of this quantity
that's the tilted cut
the cut width of the graph is the one in
which you draw you know sort of you drop
this
and you look at the you know sort of
minimum maximum cut over linear ordering
yes
you might not know but like we were
somebody was telling us yesterday about
morris and contagion and
the notion of cohesiveness which
yes so is this tilted cut with
is
yes yes it is so um
turns out
that
the heating rate of convergence is
exponential
in this quantity that i showed you
um so
um essentially when we look at the
gamma so you have to look at not just
the tilt the cockpit of the graph itself
but also all of this sub graphs
and two special cases of our interest
are you know when h is equal to zero
when the technologies are exactly the
same
in general sort of when you talk about
the you know icing model this is where
you don't have a magnetic field and that
was in a sort of a study by kenya
and you know sort of a result of the
generalization of that
when you set better equal to infinity
uh better is the
you know
the noise uh the inverse of the notes so
better including
best response dynamics and that's the
dynamics that more is looked at you will
get
so then you want
this to be equal to zero
and that will recover the notion of
cohesiveness
is a little bit algebra but it's
essentially a generalization of um
yes
no better infinitely just like pure
response
oh yes so
um essentially the limit of beta going
to infinity
is the same as k and r the epsilon goes
to zero
there is a small difference
and the difference is the following in
the kmr the epsilon is the same for
everybody
in this dynamics
if you have a higher degree
the probability that you make a mistake
is this smaller because the difference
between the two players is
could it be that
sort of for some graphs because you have
to choose better really huge and for
other graphs
yeah that's a very good question we
don't answer we
so we just look at the limit of uh
noise going to zero or the beta
and i thought that you relied on
existence of noise to say that you do
get to this
state yes
very good point so better equal to
infinity is different from better going
to infinity then
limit is different so better equal to if
it means there is no noise
right so then you can get a structure in
this local option
but now
function and the question i'm asking is
that how fast
but morris is better equal
morris is yes so
you know essentially that beta is equal
to infinity we need this to be in order
for the dynamics to go to all plus
we need this to be exactly equal to zero
which means that we don't have any
cohesive group
so essentially it says
you always want this to be bigger than
the cut
that essentially means that you know
that that recovers the definition of not
having the cohesive
appeal
but how does beta when you take the beta
equals infinity how do you recover more
as
where does
beta yeah so when you think better equal
to infinity you want this quantity to be
not to be equal to zero i see so
essentially if you think about the this
whole notion of you know getting the
stock in local optimal for you know in
order to go to all plus essentially
because there's no local optimal you
don't get to start anywhere so it means
that these are your sort of barriers
that means that you have no barriers you
don't have any don't get this budget
or
now the proof and that you know sort of
takes me to christian's question is you
know where does this quantity come from
you start from some
sort of opening configuration starting
configuration and you want to go to the
all plus
i mean you know so when you go to all
plus your potential function is that
it's highest possible value but when
you're at this starting point you have
to first decrease the potential function
before you can increase it
right so
think about this example that i showed
you on the grid with you know everybody
doing the plus when somebody you know
sort of made a mistake i decreased the
potential function
so the time it will take
is you know sort of
proportional to this you know how much
you have to decrease the potential
function because before you can increase
it among all the different paths that go
from this starting point to our plus
so you start from your
starting point you look at all the
different paths that will take you to
all plus you look at the one that
decreases the potential function the
least and that e to the power beta of
that length is the um
it determines the rate of uh the rate of
convergence you know sort of the heating
time yes
there should be a single stable for it
first or there could be potentially many
things
yes there are many peaks and valleys
like the green example that i showed you
there are many many local opponents so
this is the
this is the
best case scenario so you look at
yourself from the starting point
you know what's like sort of cat that
doesn't decrease the potential function
uh
decreases the potential function as
little as possible that determines uh
it needs to prove
that that determines the rate of the
sort of convergence
will never go through any of the other
detracting local minima
um
yeah so in the limit it does address and
in the limit that's the that determines
uh exactly you know something
my question because it's minimum now
so from your picture i would guess it's
sort of more like half or one third or
whatever
but since this is a general graph it
could happen by just this
yes one vertex you have change or it's
the last one
absolutely so i haven't answered your
question fully and i'll show some
examples uh and hopefully that will
build some information let me not get
into
sort of some of the uh mathematical
details and sort of the dual notion for
the tilted um
cut within the tilted cut
instead you know sort of try to
you know demonstrate uh this theorem on
a specific graph you know sort of
sequences like expanders that nicole
mentioned or some other graphs so we can
see the behavior there
so
um
i don't know if i should define it here
i would say a graph is lambda comma
delta expander if and only if for every
sub you know every uh subset s of
vertices whose cardinality is less than
or equal to delta the number of edges
that are leaving that subset is
proportional to the size of the
uh to the size of the cut to the size of
the subset
so if i if you take one subset and you
look at you know how many of its edges
are going outside uh or what fraction of
the you know sort of but the number of
edges are going up outside over the
cardinality of that set is lower bounded
by this lambda and that says i would say
it's a lambda expander and you know
certainly you can have the lambda comma
delta there you only need to check it
for subsets of size less than or equal
to delta
now
the graph is not very segregated
yes exactly so it means the graph is
very very connected you don't have these
clusters uh that matt was talking about
you know sort of the subsets that talk
about themselves and they're sort of
well connected among themselves but not
very well connected to anyone else so it
turns out that if the graph is an
expander the gamma star is bounded away
um
so
this essentially gamma star is linear in
that
what does that mean
it means that the hitting time could be
exponential enough so if you have a
bounded degree expander so if you have
let's say you know five uh regular
random graph
um it won't behave like they will allow
into the power five so it's not the
degree that is important it's you know
sort of the very connectedness of the
network or in a sort of
yes so if your graph is a good expander
it means that you know it will behave
much closer to a complete graph and not
convince or not
remind me what's the definition of gaps
thought is the tilted cockpit that i was
talking about so remember the
um
the rate of convergence was e to the
power of beta times gallons so
this is the tilted cut with the
dimension
yes
typically one looks at the mixing time
of the bubble dynamics which is not
reaching all once it's just making
reaching the stationary yes would they
be in the same scaling yes because as
better goes to infinity you know major
concept has about all one
but
it is not
you know as better in the limit
by the way if i say
you know 90
or plus
it doesn't really make a difference
because the bottleneck is exactly the
place where half of your vertices are
plus half of your vertices are minus
that's where you have the worst value of
the potential function so imagine you
have you know sort of you have like sort
of you know let's say you have a
random regular you have a good expander
for every single vertex switching is
very costly
when you think about let's say if
everyone is doing minus for some one
person to switch to plus we're going to
switch quickly back to minus
right in order to
you know sort of and then maybe two or
five or ten vertices switch to plus
again they switch back you really need
like half of your vertices to switch to
plus for everyone else to follow
and that the probability of that is very
small it's exponentially small but once
you go over that you know sort of half
of your vertices then you start you know
sort of the dynamics will push you to
all plus
this is what i don't understand why
reaching majority of classes
and from that you will get to all
classes quickly because there's still
lots of access
there's some noise but you have a very
strong drift towards on plus so you will
go to all costs and then you will have
some jumps ph
ph's are driving at the edges
right so between the minus and plus
plus is slightly favorable because of
the edge
yeah
but
unfavorable so strongly that very
quickly you will get uh reasonably
quickly get all classes basically graph
is large there's lots of exceptions
right somebody by randomness they still
in the minus sure so i guess the story
that i told you believe it for the
complete graph right because if
everybody is interacting with everybody
if more than a certain fraction of
vertices switch to plus then all of a
sudden is responsible yeah well for
example so my point is that for
expanders it behaves essentially in the
same way
or maybe he just needs a better so large
that your exceptions are so unlikely
that it doesn't destroy it
yeah i guess the greatest consonants and
responders that we probably wouldn't
have even if you reached it
yeah
but okay
yep
like in in in a good expander
basically like a complete graph like if
you have only all miners it's just
taking a long time to get to the balance
to get the majority yes and that is why
but once you get the majority it's fine
exactly so you have like let's say the
complete graph you have all minus here
and all plus there are
you know
potential versus the other right
right and then you have to go to this
state in which it's like let's say half
and half the potential function is much
lower so you have to go through this
bottleneck to come to the other side and
in order to go through the bottom you
need a lot of people to make mistakes
we're going to sort of do this
take this action that's not this
responsible
and that's why it takes a very long time
so i think what the confusion is right
as long as beta is fine
this
finally get into set of all classes a
little misleading because even once
you're there
you always have fluctuations away from
it and so that the better they're
constant
then you would have a constant number of
vertices
[Music]
scale with n
and make better scale within such a way
that this thing is going to come out
nicely relatively nicely right but then
you can ask oh what about finite data
like really find that better in that
case i have to worry about not hitting
all plus but have to define the
neighborhood on our plus and sort of
talk about that but makes things a
little bit
makes the notation a little bit more
complex but the message is the same
all right so convergence time is
exponential say for random regular
graphs of power like that so these
are all the result measures randomly
absolute expanders
[Music]
we know they are expanders uh this is a
sort of old result so we know
convergence time heating time is
exponential for that so even though the
degree is uh bounded uh or the average
degree is bounded in these cases
since your better changes system
so
is it exponentially large
so it's better is infinite
yeah so i understand that you have this
question about how better it is
but if better as infinite
is it still converged in finite time or
will it also because once it's infinite
right so if it's equal to infinity like
when you do best response dynamics you
don't necessarily reach the outputs
now my question is
if it gets nearer to infinity does it
take you longer to get to this
absolutely why because the learning the
convergence times e to the power of beta
that quantity all right
let's let me ask you a question
is it related to how well this country
came like things that i could better
vary
but this is depend on
how basically how how big
the max
the rate of convergence depends on data
and it depends on the graph
so yeah the thing that cut it doesn't
depend on
so essentially you can say this depends
on the gain and depends on the graph and
the way this to a sort of component is
in this particular analysis e to the
power of data
all right good now this is an expanded
graph let's look at the graph that is
you know sort of constrained by the you
know some low dimensional geometry like
a
you know d dimensional grid um so in a d
dimensional grid what you know is that
you know sort of uh
if you think about a subset that sort of
uh
let's say i you know fix one vertex and
look at the ball of radius r around it
the number of vertices inside you know
grows like r to the power d the number
of vertices on the boundary is r to the
power d minus one
so essentially
the size of the cut grows sublinearly
and because of that it can show that the
gamma star is of one
right because the the s of h the sum of
the h i in s grows linearly this one
is growth sub linearly so eventually
that takes over so what this says is
that the convergence time is fast for
all finite range graphs
so you know d dimensional grids as long
as you know your vertices are only you
know sort of you are on some low
dimensional geometry vertices only talk
to are connected to ones that are close
to them
um so
you know sort of think of this as the
you know in contrast with expanders
um there you know sort of when you have
an a type of expander convergence is a
slow here convergence is fast
[Music]
then you know it's bad and if it's
smaller than it has the power alpha you
know it's you know you know there is
it's bigger than equal to s over longest
for all subsets or for some subsets so
if you just had this inequality with s
over log s yeah
the best thing i would be able to prove
is some sort of it won't be it will be
exponential
uh like n over log n
because for this term
to take over the linear term
i need to make the number of vectors
large enough and off the top of my head
you know the number of vertices won't be
you know sort of linear it will but
still it will be large enough that i
won't be getting all one i will be
getting something that's so linear but
super constant but what is it even the
graph that has behavior like s over log
x it's not it's not this what's the
natural model of the graph this is
natural and expanders is natural and in
between is what i just take this graph
in two dimensions the other direction i
make a complete graph
and then i
adjust the width of the complete graph
at the size of your neck
it's like a product
or maybe the woods is longer than monday
right
there
networks are good examples for models in
between where you have the no
dimensional geometry but you have these
long range maps
so
for example you you know sort of you put
vertices on a grid every vertex is
connected to its you know
nearby in a sort of nodes but then every
sort of pair of vertices u and v you add
an edge with probability proportional to
one over the
manhattan distance of this uh d of u and
v to the power r
and now this parameter or you can change
if r is zero then you're essentially in
a sort of every vertex is connected to
something uniformly at random four and
as you increase r
you make these edges shorter so
essentially you favor your neighbors
that are closer to you compared to the
um the ones that are further away and
then you can say i'm going to change
this r and see what happens
so
if
r is bigger than or equal to d
essentially when you have you know sort
of uh
short range edges then the tilted cut
width becomes or you know
becomes
omega of log n over log log n so
essentially what happens is that you
have this cluster somewhere you have
this community of people who are well
connected to each other
and what happens is that they serve as a
barrier
you know they don't let the you know
sort of the you know sort of the
switching from minus two plus you know
it may happen everywhere else but since
these guys are connected among
themselves and not very well connected
to everyone else they you know sort of
resist the peer pressure from the rest
of the world for the longest time so
they switch last
if r is a smaller than d essentially you
can show that the graph is an expander
therefore uh you know sort of is going
to be exponential
so to sum it up
if
you have a d dimensional finite range
network then you know your hitting time
is constant or e to the power beta times
some constant in a small world with r
bigger than or equal to d
um
it's um e to the power beta something
that's logarithmic this should be a
smaller um then you know it you know
sort of similar to random regular graphs
or other type of
expanders the hitting time is going to
be exponentially large
that's the sort of summary of what i
showed you
should i wait for it
i'm not going to do it but this is the
smaller
yeah good question we didn't do it
these are the examples
[Music]
is let's assume like some of the h are
my negatives
would that like give it a dynamic it's
like inaccurate we're not everything is
going to be perfect
oh i see they are talking about like
mixed regimes enriching the sort of some
communities are doing you know who are
taking one action and another community
is doing another one absolutely actually
this is what we see
uh you know sort of for example with the
facebook and instagram you know example
that
um uh
matt mentioned and this could be for two
reasons one is that you know sort of if
you are you know a 15 year old you want
to be in there you know sort of on the
same platform as people are you know
sort of around the same age and also you
don't want to be on the same platform as
you know people are you know who are you
know your parents age so in that sense
you will see the
sort of the same relationship
um like this is yours because of this
you don't always have the structures
like one good example is your sort of
online dating platforms every you know
sort of five to seven years you have a
new one
especially because people who are
younger don't want to be on the platform
um
no this is interesting so at article 2d
something very interesting happens right
so there's this result
please ask me is one of them strict yes
one of them is a string
less than or equal to d is an expander
so that r is exactly equal to the when
you actually see the small board
phenomena like that the climber observed
still you have an expander
so
you have equality here
you have equality here but not here so
this is a strip that we are smaller this
is bigger than
yeah that's all i'm saying this is less
than a report and this is the stream yes
my apologies
the case where you have equality you
have an example
now climber had thought of this
observation that only at exactly the
polynomial
yes and if it's
um
no we don't see that because think about
the case that's you know sort of um or
is equal to zero exactly
right in that case what happens in a
sort of sort of climax result
is that you have this long you have all
of your limbs are really long
so you can get close to the destination
but for the last mile you have a problem
because since all the edges are so long
you know when you get near sort of
relatively close you have to walk the
rest of it like you have to
and
sorry if i don't elaborate on
christian's question but it's about a
different result on um finding shortcuts
in a social method
in a network
all right
um
so this is uh
you know we can't observe this right
away but this is in contrast with
contagion dynamics where you know when
you have the spirit of an infection the
behavior spreads from an infected mode
to a healthy labor you know when it's
independent like the contact process um
high degree nodes
help with the spread of the dynamics
right or you know if you have a very
very connected network somewhere in your
network essentially you know sort of
that when it gets saying friction it
contains the infection from
this statement i made was about
hiding sort of well connected networks
and by degree ones if you have high
degree notes and if you have
well-connected graphs infections are
threatened quickly yes right yeah if
it's high degree engines were connected
essentially you have an expander i said
you have an extender it means that
exactly that's the message so
when you let's say you have a product
that you certainly wanted to be adopted
in a social network you have to think
about how is it going to spread is it a
spread more like a virus or does it
describe more like the
dynamics of the coordination do people
use it because you know they find out
about it from their neighbors or they
use it because everyone in their
neighborhood a lot of people in the
neighborhood is going to use that like
that there is a sort of a
big difference uh let's say you want a
venture capitalist and you want to
really sort of invest in some upcoming
discipline you have to think about you
know how hard it is for um
sort of
competing with competing with the
for the new technology to become to
compete with the
incumbent technology
um
and also oh yes
[Music]
yeah so again it depends on you know
whether you think people believe that
because every you know sort of because
of the yes
oh i see um
i i don't know i don't know if they're
economists or social scientists
when it comes to spread of
misinformation should we think of it
more as the
contingent process or the
dynamics of the coordination game
hard to say
one of the challenges that i get to this
is that you know when it comes to sort
of this question of influence you know
uh maximization
the thought that i was supposed to give
was on this you know imagine
you have um
you know sort of a contagion process
making sort of you see the humanoids in
your social network and then fiction
spreads saying like your you know
warrants then identifying the set of
influential
nodes is
relatively easy in the sense that there
are good approximation elements right
there's a one minus one of the
approximation if i change the column to
that which is a very valid part paper
you know there is a paper that i think
is going to present in one of the
workshops that we show that even sort of
choosing your seeds randomly is not so
bad
um
so if you're in this world and the
interesting you know the most important
you know sort of feature uh is you know
sort of in you know when you're in the
contagion dynamics is that when you look
at the probability of the adoption it
has this like sort of diminishing return
it's like concave the probability that
you adopt as a function of the number of
friends adopting the sort of
is uh
somewhat you know sort of as you know
sort of the
as as you have more friends um adopting
the technology the
impact of the additional person becomes
a smaller additional friend becomes
smaller and smaller
so here you know when you're in the
contagion dynamics the problem becomes
relatively easy
you can you know sort of give good
algorithms for it
but when you have more of this threshold
behavior
like you know sort of um
then you know sort of similar to
coordination games that i mentioned um
then uh even the problem of you know
sort of who are the right people to see
becomes very difficult so it's actually
np hard to give them an o of n to the
power minus one minus epsilon
uh
uh approximation for it and i think you
know sort of math mentioned something
along those lines that you know here you
want to spread the seeds so you wanna
sort of find uh you know a few high
degree people and
sort of get them to adopt your
technology but if you are have a
technology that has a very high you know
sort of um
you know sort of people adopted because
a lot of people in their you know
immediate neighborhood is going to adopt
it let's say if i go back to the example
of online dating you cannot have like
one person in san francisco and five
people in atlanta and you know four
people in new york city are using your
app because each one of them will log in
and they will not find the people that
serve
that they are looking for so they stop
using that you want to you know sort of
win you know sort of
college by college high school by high
school uh
so the type of you know sort of seeding
that you will do uh will be very
different like it's not surprising for
faith that facebook is spread from you
know sort of college to college right it
was a very smart strategy yes hey for
your second point here
solving for the uh isn't hard but if i
gave you a solution does this imply
or close to optimum
initial seed set
so
yeah maybe i didn't pause it right so
okay right so there are two questions
right so one is that i give you a graph
can you
uh that's a bit hard that's it you know
they might give you the solution so i'm
an oracle yes can i tell you that this
is the optimal like
i don't know it's a good question we are
so if you have access to that or a call
couldn't you have the situation that
they thought of the hardest cut right
but then you sort of have lower overcuts
which are still hard
and so now you have to give me those as
well awesome
right keep all the all the cats that are
high
and seed all of them let go
i see so you have an oracle you can ask
for
i guess since you know this is the start
of the program the start of the semester
there are a lot of interesting
algorithmic questions uh related to
you know sort of influencing or
controlling uh sort of a stochastic
process on the network now you know in
the case of like
spread of viruses maybe you want to you
know
test the quality or vaccinate people to
sort of make it as small as possible or
you wanna you know in the case of uh you
know online marketing you want the you
know the the product or the technology
and spread that sort of much as possible
or as fast as possible very interesting
questions many of them very challenging
at least in the worst case you have to
you know sort of make assumptions about
the structure of the network i look
forward to
talking to you about all of those
and i'll stop here